الصوره دائما ما تكون ابلغ من الوصف وهنا
حجم الدمار يفوق قدره الاستيعاب حين يمتد
على مساحه تتجاوز حجم دول لكن قبل الصوره
ستساعدنا الجغرافيا تقع المناطق المتضرره
بالدرجه الاولى على خط الصدع الزلزلي في
تركيا المقاطعات المنكوبه يفصلها الخط
المميت وحين نشات بؤره الزلزال الاول فجرا
في الرابعه وتسعه عشره دقيقه ضرب بقوه
كانت اقرب الى ثمان درجات بؤره في عمق ضحل
لم يتجاوز 18 كيلومترا فكان اثره على
السطح مهولا هذا فقط اثر الزلزال الاول
الممتد من غاز عنتاب الى جميع الولايات
التي حلت عليها النكبه شديد القوه الى
متوسط الاثر ونرى تاثيره يمتد الى دول عده
سوريا بالطبعه الشركه في الكارثه فلسطين
لبنان قبرص اليونان والدنمارك 11 دقيقه
بعدها ارتدت الضربه بهزه وصلت قوتها
6.6 درجات جاءت على ما تبقى من البيوت
والمباني ولم تمضي ساعات تسع ساعات ضرب
الزلزال الثاني كهرمان مرعش في منطقه
البستان وتوالت الهزات بعدها في الاسبوع
الاول
1800 هزه سجلت فما كان ليصمد انهار بهزات
متتاليه تراوحت قوتها بين اربع وست درجات
هنا اقليم هاتاي وهذه انطاكيا او بقايا
بقايا مكانه ثالث اهم مدينه في العالم
ابان العصر الروماني بعد روما والاسكندريه
سوقها القديم لا يميزه سوى المقارنه وهنا
للصوره رائحه يصفها سكان انطاكيا برائحه
الموت حجم الدمار مشاهدينا عصي على الفهم
50% من مبانيها اختفت عن رصد الاقمار
الصناعيه وما كان ياخذ ساعه للوصول الى
انطاكيا اخذ ثمان ساعات بسبب الطرق
المتصدعه ولا يوجد سوى طريقين رئيسيين الى
المدينه هذه الطرق نفسها هي التي عطلت
امدادات الاغاثه الى شمال السوري في
الايام الاولى التي تلت الزلزال نحو معبر
باب الهوى واحد واربعون الف مبنى في تركيا
تعرض للتدمير الكلي او الجزئي لكن الضرر
يقتصر على السطح وعلى المباني منها
الشاهقه سويت بالارض البنيه التحتيه
لشبكات المياه والصرف الصحي في المناطق
المنكوبه تضررت حد اختلاط المياه الشرب
بمياه المجاري وكم يستغرق الوقت لاصلاحها
هنا بعد الصور والجغرافيا علينا الاستعانه
بالتاريخ وليس البعيد
1999 زلزال ازميت في مركزه مدينه جولت
تشوك تدمر نظام الصرف الصحي ونظام تصريف
مياه الامطار بالكامل اضافه الى 80% من
طرق المدينه اعاده اعمارها بالكامل
استغرقت اربع سنوات وهذه مدينه واحده
انحسرت فيها تقريبا اضرار الزلزال المدمر
وحينها ورفعت فيها الانقاض بعد قضاء 17
الف شخص تحتها فكم بمساحه 480 كيلومتر
مربع في تركيا في جنوبها المنكوب الدمار
فيه يمتد على مساحه توازي مساحه دول
كفرنسا مناطق مهدده وستبقى مهدده بخطر
انتشار الاوبئه والامراض المعديه مع طول
بقاء الضحايا تحت انقط
[موسيقى]
العم
ليات ركزوا على انتشال الجثث الموتى
والمفقودين وفرق الانقاذ بدات تاخذ شكلا
ولونا جديدا ترتدي ملابس العزل خشيه
الامراض والاوبئه وانتشارها
[موسيقى]